good morning ladies and gentlemen uh are
we on YouTube okay yep proper job
welcome members of the public listening
on YouTube as well to this meeting of
community and resources
committee uh the budget setting the main
meeting of the Year
almost
um item one apologies for
absence chair we've had apologies from
councelor Christie and from councelor
Whitaker thank you are there any
substitutes no substitutes chair okay
right we are
quar item two public contributions is
anyone asked to speak registered to
speak
no item three Declarations of Interest
the normal warning but most if not all
of you are well experienced counselors
you know the
score item four agreement of the agenda
between Parts one and two there is
nothing scheduled for part two so that
is
fine number five urgent matters brought
forward by the chairman I have
none so we're already on to item six
Miss anous fees and
charges yep drive on thank you chair so
yes as mentioned agenda item six is the
annual review of fees and charges so
fees and charges an important part of
the funding of the council they make up
the largest single element at almost 8
million
pound so for the last few months Finance
staff and service staff have been
working together to look to uplift
charges now the the direction that's
been given to them in consultation with
leading with senior members is to keep
up with inflation for the most part so
that's been the general guide and this
is because with uh with business rates
and with central government funding and
with council tax not being able to go up
by inflation where we do have some
discretion we think it's important that
we do try to maintain um that that level
as that funding support as much as
possible so it's not been about
increasing the amount of resources we
get from charges but it's about not
going backwards this year and that's
been the focus of what we've been of
what we've been aiming for um so that's
not always been the case there has been
certain examples where charges have gone
down so you'll notice that where there's
been changes to tax treatment the the
the charge to the to the to the to the
clients will actually have gone down
although we're still maintaining the
level of funding to ourself and there
are also other situations where for
reasons of Public Safety we've chosen to
reduce the level of cost of of cost such
as with Beach safety at Westwood hope
the cost of that
certification um so so thank you chair
the appendix details pretty much all of
the charges that we operate and that we
um recommend being implemented as of
next year I'm happy to accept any
questions okay councelor hes thank you
chair um
yeah two questions the the cemetery that
relates to the one in of the Val road is
it it it will be all torage
cemeteries yeah what's the sit what's
the situation with the one in bville do
we share revenue on that yeah so so this
this report doesn't include charges
against the um the crematoria that's
that's set by the the joint committee so
we can use that revenue from yeah the
bonds and the other one I understand
that the resident charges
um there's been an amendment for
residents charges to accommodate people
who now working from home um particular
I'm to sorry to raise bone Hill again
because I was accused of being parochial
last time um but I understand there's a
a reduction or a new a new set of
charges which uh are slightly cheaper is
that right for yeah I mean that's that's
a that's a good news part of this that
um fees and charges process yeah so
there were some people previously who
fell between um fell between different
charging regimes and now there's a um um
a permit that's in place for people that
do do shift
work and that's specific to particular
zones on so I'm just trying to give
information from what I've gathered
earlier um so there a reduction now from
sun up to Monday Sunday to Sunday it's
350 and
Sunday to Saturday it's 294 is that
right
okay councelor lock yeah mine just one
full point I've got a resident in one of
my parishes who needs to have a proof of
Life certificate signed and sealed every
year bord Town Council did it for many
years free of charge then she came to
torich and they charged £25 and last
year it went up to
50 which she thought was exhaustion
she's gone to Deon County and they do it
free of charge but under what section of
your report does the proof of Li
certificate come
under
please I'm I'm sorry I can't answer that
off the top of my head I'll have to get
back to you on
that I couldn't see anywhere where it
was
included talking of things not
included I couldn't see where income
assuming there is some from the cad
Stone business units the hols of the
business units
appear I didn't find it but it may be
here what pages
all no I think for the most part they
negotiated individually
Che yeah they would be negotiated
individually I accept that what page are
you
on3 Council lock it's page 25 I'm
talking of the income from all the
commercial
unit well where does the income from
them go
so if I'm not picking it up on our
budgets that goes CH if I may so there's
different lines for property rents which
are not part of our anual fees and
charges because they are agreed on
long-term rents rather than individual
anyal fees and
charges fine but where do they show on
the income they show they'll show in the
budget as a line for rental income from
our property estate this is just the
fees in charges this is just the fees
yeah I know I'm trying to get it you
know where this income is going where
it's coming from or you know we know
where it's coming from but I'm curious
as to where it's going and how much it
is here's as I understand it this is
only setting the actual fees the various
incomes we get like for car par they're
not identified either are they as
individual things so we don't actually
know on this particular set of figures
what the actual amounts are per um year
Financial year what we're actually
getting in from it but uh and that would
apply to the cstone as well I presume
and therefore but we're just setting the
fees now as next year by according to
what we agree today in terms of setting
fees we'll know what the the global
income is from each one for this coming
Financial year but we we'd have to look
at last year's figures I presume to see
what what we got from cstone for example
and and as long as we're not running at
a loss and as I understand it from this
we're not going to make a profit out of
uh out of cstone which not supposed to
do as I understand it um we're all right
setting the fees that we're proposing
today is that
right um yeah yeah that's fine it's
about um full cost recovery um for the
for the most part so that's the that
that is something that we Aspire towards
but isn't always possible but certainly
within the budget papers will be within
them the various income
strands
separate issue chair I think we're here
to discuss the fees and charges and and
if we start looking at what else we
should be doing we're moving away from
what the report is so I would like to
recommend the report as it
is
no
question questions
chair uh and I'll start I'll follow on
councilor haes who started with
cemeteries which
um it it says on cemeteries that there's
a reduction resident reduction on below
below fees marked with an a what is that
reduction because I can't see it
anywhere how much is it
and what that what does it mean a
reduction for Resident TDC resident
reduction
P page four of the
uh um yeah I mean it's shown at the top
of the page it's a 25% reduction for
residents well beg you paron it does
yeah yeah and the other the the other
one is exclusive rights to burial for 20
years now it's quite a hefty fee there
what happens after 25 25 years I mean
it's not clear to me what that means you
don't get it for imp perpetuity then so
what happens then with that
grave after 25 years I love
it
yeah sure I mean
techically but I'm sure members will
appreciate there's quite a lot of
discussion
around
uspr yeah that's what bothers me I'm not
happy about that but I haven't been
because it's always been in there this
this 25 years when churches it's a lot
less money to pay for a burial plot and
it's imp perpetuity that's that's all I
just think these are heck fees if after
25 years you may have had a triple one
grave you may have only used two spaces
you're going to use it lose the right to
the third space according to this then
if a family member after 25 years dies
they don't they can't use a vacant space
in that grave then and what happens to
that vacant space that's all I'm asking
what happens to that I would have
thought it's yours for the rest of
Eternity really once you paid for
it it runs with a 25 year exclusivity
point so it expires so you could bury
anybody in there afterwards if there's
space um technically yes yes um however
having had discussions with experts
around centries that that raises a
number of moral discussions which I'm
sure would be appreciated so uh it's
something which is a bit of a dilemma
for managing something where you have a
nature where you have an exclusive
exclusivity Arrangement that
expires there's no easy way around it um
you know it is one of the considerations
that the council will need to have going
forward in terms of its cry
capacity um and you know there'll be a
separate discussion around capacity and
and how Senator are managed which you
know will pick up this point it's not
the intention is not necessarily to
answer that point here and there but it
will be one of the points of discussion
that members will need to
consider right well I I won't do too
much more on this but I mean if you look
at the charges for a single double and
triple plot and you get a 25% reduction
if you're a TDC
resident then you look on top of that
you've got to pay for this exclusive
right which again is quite a hefty fee
to me and then we'll leave that for
future discussion the other thing um
occurs to me is on the car Parks Apple
do car park for um motor homes it's the
most expensive car park there is all the
others are 8 and £1 to par and down
appledore all the year round if you have
a motor home15 all all the
time now Westwood Hall main car park
smaller than churchfield car park but
it's £8 and
11 so I don't know why Apple go it's
probably to stop motor homes going down
there if that's the thinking behind it I
don't think very much of it to be
honest um from recollection there was a
notice motion brought by Council Ford on
this very item um and there was a
lengthy community and resources debate
at which the that differential in
charges was was Set uh and it was partly
to uh I think if against the backdrop of
the covid pandemic and and the release
of lockdown and we were the massive
influx of motor homes that come in there
were problems in church Fields so a Zone
was set and a higher Tariff was set to
help manage and perhaps to a certain
extent discourage uh motor homes from
congregating in that area so there was
quite a lengthy cni debate on that
one I was just going to point out the
same thing sorry obviously on the new
car park wilis field there's no parking
and motor homes at
all I haven't finished yet
chair I've not finished yet on Northern
Burrows commercial rent of land per day
commercial rent of land per season or sh
I'm sure you can answer that what's that
about what what commercial rent for What
on Northern
bar sh so um this is some of the events
that we license to uh skar or other
places companies like that who
occasionally uh do like a popup day of
an activity down there on the barels
itself the bars itself what happens to
the grazi is right in that case uh I'm
not sure that's been considered anywhere
chair I don't know I'd need to consult
with Mike on that but I it's not
something that's ever come up in any
discussion I've ever had so well it
might do in future it might
do right I think I've nearly done and
then then lease
agreements Garden lease Administration
free and garden lease termination fee
what's a garden lease what Gardens do we
lease out
there wasn't any fee 2324 but it's
proposed 2425
3150 for both of
those on page 20 yeah chair um I I I
can't say what those are off the top of
my head I'm sorry but I'll be able to
get back to you on
that
lot there's a lot of questions really
and on the car on the car parking chair
on the car parking there are a lot of
questions I would have had I I don't
think we should just be rubber stamping
increases like this and also the annex
Pages the fees and
charges types of development I printed
it off here it doesn't say what this is
is this for actual planning
applications or is it
for um preapplication
there's no it doesn't show anywhere
about what preapplication charges
are yeah this is the everything
development management related so
there's certain fees which are set by
statutes and there's certain fees which
are set locally and these are the fees
that are set
locally and what are they for fees for
what plan pre application yeah
pre-application advice yeah Why didn't
it say it at the top then say on page
no it doesn't say
itend I just thought they're quite steep
those I wondered if they were
pre-application and I think they're
quite steep
there it puts people off actually making
some planning pre inquire used to be
free didn't it it used to be no charge
at all you could get you know let's not
for that rate payers are paying a lot of
money in rates these days and what
services used to be free now are being
charged for and I understand why we've
got to raise income but you know it's we
shouldn't be doing it willingly and
sometimes I think we are doing it
without giving it the proper thought
they're not cheap those fees and IT
Major developers know it won't put them
off but smaller ones I think could be
put off and and just go straight to
planning we without bother me that and I
always try to advise residents that it's
worth having a preapp inquiry but the
some of these charges make you think
again to be honest thanks
chair chair question is my question is
do other councils do it how long have we
been doing it and is there an increase
because we can't see what it's an
increase I if it's a common thing for
all
councils I can't recall the time but I
can remember having a full debate about
setting charges for prea and the amount
of time our officers were spending on
pre apps so they were getting a free
service which actually saves the
applicant money in the long run because
we sort out all the the little quirks of
some of the planning at the preup stage
so they they're not getting tied down
when it comes to the full application
and in some cases it saved applicants
wasting money doing applications that
are not going to go past the preup stage
so we've had full debate about that our
charges when it was near zero was out of
line with most other councils they did
charge and the charge we've set is was
set after a long discussion of what we
consider was a fair charge considering
the time that our officers were spending
doing it and as we know um in recent
times they've spent you know they
they've had a heavy workload and you
know people putting in pre pre apps
sometimes with no opportun no hope of
getting the plan in was just taken up
time so we've virtually done what every
other council do and we charge a similar
charge to what other councils do and
that's gone through this various
committees on several
occasions
I'm not arguing against doing them it's
the level of them I think and I I hear
what you say about West Devon being more
expensive than we are and I hear what
councel James says but preapps don't
stop planning applications going in you
you said you said about no no chance of
getting no chance of getting an
application they don't determine that at
all at preapps it's just a discussion
around what somebody's proposing I mean
when you look at small and minor another
235 I just think where have we ever been
involved as elected members in setting
these fees ever I can't remember it but
I'll leave it at that because I don't
want to
labor along with many other councils
through the LGA and dcn have lobbied
hard go to government uh because
planning Ser the planning services and
planning fees because such a large
majority of our sacrific not just don't
simply don't cover the cost and like
what like you said Council they get more
and more planning applications in yes
you get a kind of statutory fee but
doing a lot lot more work um in advance
getting them right because you know we
all we all know the time frames are set
as well and when you get things in that
are not right and causing more and more
work that causes more and more cost so
having these up front is something
that's been fought hard for and you know
as as already been said members did have
long debates over the pro process and
setting the
fees I think Council hes was asking and
I thought the same thing when I read
this through for all the other
statistics we have what they were for
the last fee setting period and for this
we obviously only have what they are now
in the in the appendix I'm just checking
my understanding because I had a look
back and I didn't see it when I first
read it but I think on page five it says
um no I've lost it page five of the
actual fees it says all the preapp fees
in that appendix have been uplifted by
the Consumer Price Index and round to
the nearest 5 pound so if there have
been no other increases from when these
were first I'm just checking my
understanding if there been no is that
the extent of the rise for those
particular charges that don't have a
2023 to 2024 is that because this yellow
box is covering all the changes that
have happened and the only thing that's
happened to those prea fees is they
they've been uplifted by CPI and rounded
is that the only change that's happened
to those since the last period thank you
chair so yes this this was the common
direction that was given to all services
so yes that will be they com up between
five and six% okay and no other change
yeah
thank you chair morning
counselors paper right together a
second so the report in front of you
today is um asking um for a
growth bid of £45,000
together with a capital um bid of
70,000 the the background uh to the
report is that our desktop strategy uh
is now five years old or coming up to be
5 years old and that's a considerable
amount of time in the um technology
world we um have looked at um our
Alternatives we're we've linked to the
um sorry we've linked to the strategy
digital by default strategy that this
committee approved a few months ago and
what we've um come up with is a um
option of a virtual desktop solution now
won't go into the details and and
Technologies of this but what what we're
looking at is all of the infrastructure
that all of the council's um technology
um or their Staffing or the emails or
their software all that what that works
on in the background so it's kind of and
I think it was counselor James mentioned
to me when I went through this with him
it's kind of the cost of business I
think was was a term he gave to me as as
we were describing it so it is your
infrastructure so that all of the
software can operate um safely and
securely and what we're looking at um is
to continue the move to the cloud uh so
that that stops um the kind of the the
buying the um uh the hardware as as it
is it's more virtual virtual Hardware
now um so what we're looking at is um a
changing to how we fund it normally
would have come to you and looked for
one big Capital bid every five years um
what we're looking at now is more of a
move to subscription and Cloud um based
and what that um means is that we we we
look at a a bit of a growth bid but when
you look at the the actual figures it is
very similar to what we paid five years
ago for the fiveyear term so it it's a
change but it's very similar um it helps
the authority with their um disaster
recovery and it also helps with um kind
of modernizing and part of the report
says about helping us future
proof um the other part of the um the
the report asks you for um some capital
and that that is the little wise boxes
they're kind of wise PCS it's what 99%
of the staff use on their desks to
access all of their systems um that they
um they're five years old they're coming
end of life the current ones and now to
move to the next step we're we're
looking to to upgrade and the new new
new versions are um more um efficient
they're they will help us um with our
kind of uh looking at um online meetings
and things like that and it will and
they're also more efficient when it
comes to energy they they you they and
they're also 60%
um use of um recycled um Plastics so
we've we've looked at kind of what
looked at it as around um so the
recommendations in front of you are for
a growth bid of um
45,000 together with a capital bid of
70,000 and I think the um counselor
James as my lead member was going to say
a few
words well I'm never confused expert so
I've been spayed by the arguments but it
does seem to me that what we've got will
run out um we will run out in August
this year so we have got to update the
system the system we're looking at will
be more efficient will show cost savings
and they're also more recyclable so you
know I fully recommend the report
because if we don't we could end up
coming to a stand still and in this day
and age I'm afraid whether we agree with
the technology or not that's where we
are so um that's about all I can really
say I've gone through it several times
with John because I've been a bit slow
on some of the uptake but I fully
endorse the
recommendation will it
require no chair it won't this is this
is this is kind of the the back end so
for for members in fact you you're you
part of your your transfer to your new
iPad uh has included a little bit of the
new technology and and yeah it it won't
it won't affect um retraining for for
counselors thank you um yeah I was just
interested in is it involves disposal of
old disposal of old equipment do it so
what happens to them uh we we've got a
um a contract and a disposal um policy
that we have to abide by because of the
Technologies involved um and they are
all certified and um they are also
um from from a green ele element they
they look to to uh repackage anything
that they
can right thank
you thanks John so just to clarify are
we predominantly on a server based
system at the moment
yeah we're we're on a server based
system um some
virtual um and some in our server room
at um Riverbank house with a backup at
uh
cadan and and will this change then put
us completely onto a cloudbased
system not quite it's it's part it's our
direction of travel basically so um it
will it will take a a locked there um I
think kind of some of the current
servers are will come end of life in
three years time some of the some of
them and that's when we'll come and then
we'll do another report to say let's
move the final lots to the
cloud um the other question was do we
have a contingency for implementation
that the Lite in me always gets a bit
nervous when you change Compu system so
I didn't know if that had been factored
in or needed to be yeah absolutely and
and to be fair the you're not the only
one we my my team are absolutely um very
similar to that so the current system
will operate um and continue until such
time as we're happy that we can do the
switch and we've got um
um in CAD down we've we've got uh the
the back backup system that can um run
it's just that's a little bit older
technology now but we we have got that
as a as a backup if we need
it um and and then my last couple I
suppose my fundamental question which
sounds like the budget our budgets won't
be impacted because you just it's a
change of we just confirmation on that
obviously having read Gordon's next
report conscious of any impacts on the
on budget
or or are we just a change of track
rather than a change
of you know significant impacts on
budgets I suppose yeah um over the
fiveyear period from the last one to
kind of looking forward going on the
annual cost was very similar so it is uh
we're looking um it is a change of track
of kind of how we have to pay it now
rather than you know we're coming for a
big lump or or a big growth
bid sounds like a good move thanks
John thank you
chair I written down here in the margin
yesterday built-in obsolesence this
system's only been in not even for five
years quite yet by the end of August I
take it it will be five years um and it
will it require this quite a bit of
financial invest significant it says all
the page it mentions a final benefit of
this solution which is being proposed
and Cloud adoption may be realized at
the end of the project in 2027 that's
not very far away where there will be an
opportunity to remodel the delivery of
all the council's virtual
infrastructure including the remaining
riverb House Server Side workloads by
building on the investment in this
virtual de Des stock solution well we
don't know exactly what it is it's a bit
of a mouthful that paragraph there I
think but it means that in a few years
time we're going to be spending another
fortune and mind this is hardware I
realize but I'm mindful that only last
year we spent a considerable sum on
software a big software update and that
won't be affected by changing to these
obviously I hope well I'm sure it won't
be because I don't think um a technical
staffer would be buying in software that
ain't going to work on these new wise
computers but yeah builting offer
lessons happens in all things now your
mobile phones and that and you know you
spend a lot of money on these things and
the and the manufacturers of them build
in so after two three years certain
certain things won't run or they won't
support certain things it's a proper
racket really in many instances thanks
chair
I understand uh that you're asking 200
of our old computers would that be used
to offset if anybody chooses to buy the
old iPads of the
75k and secondly I've got material on my
own computer that I was a little bit
shamed to lose nothing nothing uh that's
illegal or anything like that but I
didn't want to lose it um but sitation
such that that I just wonder if that's
going to offset the cost of the 75k if
you achieve 200 for all the oabs that
you're
selling well they qued me 50 it you're
far better dealer than I am I'll go
through Char me
50 um it it all depends on the model and
uh of the iPad that you currently got
open to offers yeah we're not we're not
open to offers uh counselor the the the
policy that the committee agreed several
years ago was that we go to Apple with
the um uh code from each individual iPad
and they will tell you what the residue
value is and then that value um is
passed on to the C if they want to buy
it or not um and then the money goes
into the part I don't know what um
question come back
off
no I mean that that's the gross cost
that they that they need to deliver it
so any any income that's brought in will
go in and be available for other
services or
Investments ioun James
AC don't
have all those in favor please
show that is
yourk
next item number
eight budget medium-term Financial
strategy thank you chair so this is item
eight on the agenda um it is just the
revenue budget um so capital budget and
treasury management will be covered in
separate papers this covers the revenue
budget for next year and makes certain
high levels assumptions about the
revenue
um financial position for the next four
years after that also so this paper
covers council tax increases assumptions
around the level of
reserves assumptions around the um
changes to funding and costs and certain
risks and sensitivity to the budget
setting
process so if I could start by recapping
on where we were this time last
year and this is in section two of the
report this covers the the the funding
position there so members will note from
the table in section two um so if we
could go yes please yeah so if I could
have the second slide up
yes so this is where we were a year ago
so we still anticipated starting the
year so we have this budgetary
stabilization Reserve um which we have2
million pounds set aside to meet future
budget deficits now this time a year ago
we thought we'd be starting the year
with 1.4 million and we thought that in
every year of the mtfs there would be a
small deficit as you can see from this
as see from this
chart however it also contained certain
assumptions such as around Staffing
increases um
that to a greater lesser extent have
become accurate so this so the budget
that was set this time last year still
had a structural deficit but that
structural deficit was around one and a
half% so to update you all since we
closed the accounts for 2223 we didn't
need to draw down on the budgetary
stabilization Reserve as we envisaged um
and also it was the case over the course
of this year there's been certain
changes so if we just move on to the
next slide
please so we've eared greater income
from treasury management that was
anticipated but also of course staff pay
um the the the pay award for this year
has been greater than budgeted so all
these factors just to update you all
will have impacted upon the budget that
was set 12 months AG go this slide also
includes a key graph so members will be
aware that over recent years the cost of
temporary accommodation has gone up
enormously but because of the increases
in um in in capacity that we've
undertaken recently with the the least
households and with the the Hostel at
Sully house this is the anticipated
position as at the end of 23 24 so we
are seeing a fall um for the first time
so this is going to be really really
handy so moving on to the next next
financial year this is where we're at
now so this is just a reminder to you
all of where of where our key sources of
funding come from the largest as just
discussed is fees and charges but the
next biggest after that is business
rates and the next after that 4.8
million is council
tax and some of the graphs that we'll
show so this graph in particular um
shows the this is just reminder to you
all that even though we collect a great
deal of council tax it's only a
relatively small proportion that is
actually torage related so you can see
that the county councils and the police
are significantly larger than the share
um that that we get to keep of the
council tax we
[Applause]
collect and then moving on to the next
slide so the recommendation within the
paper is that council tax increases by 2
99% this is the maximum um that we are
able to and it's also just a reminder
that it's an annual allowance that we
have it's an annual increase that's
available and if we don't increase it by
2.99% in any one year we can't catch up
in future years if we don't increase it
um then then that lost and as the the
table on the right shows the weekly
increase so for 2/3 of our Council
taxpayers the 2.99% increase equates to
a less than a 10% increase per week and
of course the key reminder as well that
inflation for the last couple of years
has been running at a point much much
higher than
2.99% so the report also covers key
details from the the settlement so next
slide please so this is just a a
reminder that another key source of
funding for the County Council is
funding from central government so you
might have heard reported that the core
spending power has increased by 6 and a
half% um
that is a figure that looks on aggregate
across all local authorities the actual
increase in funding from central
government to torage is just over 2% and
this figure will change slightly because
we've had announcements in the last week
or so about certain increases but we
haven't yet been told what that equates
to for us but for the report that goes
to full Council you will have that that
that final piece of information but it's
just a reminder of how Reliant we are
upon other sources of funding such as
fees and charges and such as council tax
when those other bits are are controlled
by um by central government
determinations and relatively good news
business rates is going up by inflation
either because the multiplier is going
up or because the multiplier has been
held steady but support is coming from
central government
instead some other tables within the
report talk you through the process by
which the council tax level is Det
determined um for the council and that's
how the base is calculated and the
implementation of discounts um and the
local council tax support
scheme so moving on to section eight of
the report this is the budget for
2425 and the key point to bring to your
attention is the deficit figure that we
previously were looking at 12 months ago
has now um increased quite significantly
this is mostly because of
inflation so what you can see from the
report and from the presentation in
front of you is the gap between um
expenditure and income so not only is
the gap larger than it was a year ago
it's also getting bigger so when
previously we had a a structural deficit
of one and a half perc now the
structural deficit is nearer to 6% so
there are significant deficit figures
within that that will have to be
confronted the next chart also so when
you compare to that first chart that we
showed you with the budgetary
stabilization Reserve which started at a
lower figure but never actually run down
the reserve over the course of the
mtfs this this this paints a very
different picture this shows that after
year three of the current mtfs we will
have run out of the budgetary
stabilization Reserve so obviously
action needs to be taken well in advance
of
that um I will also just draw your
attention to the to the the key table
that on page 41 of the report which
gives you a complete breakdown of all
the movements on a service basis of all
the changes that have taken place
between last year's budget and this
one so if we can move on to the next
slide so these are some of the key
assumptions contained within the
mtfs so for example we are assuming that
the maximum level of council tax is set
we're making some prudent levels of
assumptions around central government
support because it's very difficult to
estimate what we'll get um for year two
of the budget and it was only of course
a one-year
settlement we're continuing to assume
certain growth in business rates there
are some higher um levels of assumptions
around future increases in staff pay and
we think that we will continue to get um
some quite useful Returns on our cash
balances for a few more years though of
course that will reduce as many is spent
on the operational Center um under the
capital
schemes and we are also assuming further
reductions for the cost of providing
temporary accommodation as more capacity
is
delivered what this graph now shows you
is the impact of not increasing um
council tax on the finances of the
authority so we know know already that
in year one we'll have a budget deficit
of half a million and by year five it
will increase to
900,000 but of course if we don't and
this is just for not increasing council
tax in one year so that will so the
difference between a zero council tax
increase and a 2.99% increase in council
tax is around £230,000 a year so of
course that increases the deficit in
each and every year and also increases
the cumulative impact of over a million
pounds so it means that the empty rather
than having A4 million pound cumulative
deficit would have A5 million P
cumulative
deficit so looking forward chair
obviously there are some significant
financial challenges contained within
this report however I don't think it's
all doom and gloom The Authority does
have a good record in delivering savings
the members budget working group um 12
months ago delivered many hundreds of
thousands of pounds worth of savings it
just means that we have to take a really
good close look at some of the
assumptions within it and some of the
way services are currently being
delivered but it will mean that we look
again at fees and charges as
well however of course you know the
revenue budget does have lots of Doom
and Gloom within it or a certain amount
of it but of course there's still a lot
to be excited about financially and the
next two to three years is going to see
a a generation level of capital capital
Investments um in in the local area
and also of course if we just move on to
the next
slide so this chose so for example the
funding Gap is the top line and that's
the assumed deficit per year but then of
course there's lots of other things that
that may occur to bring that back a bit
so for example where it comes to things
like interest on cash balances or
planning income we budget based upon
what we think we will we will bring in
but of course especially things like
planning income it can be extremely
volatile and that could move by £600,000
between a good year and a bad year and
we're budgeting currently based upon
what we think we will get so it's
entirely possible that we could bring in
more planning income next year than is
currently budgeted similarly with with
with interest as well and then of course
there's other examples of of changes
that could be brought forward we know
about the possible investment in Energy
Efficiency in in Leisure centers um and
the trading position generally is
improving there as well so so even
though there's a very large headline Gap
there are lots of ideas for how that can
be brought back into balance there's
lots of capital investment that's still
going to be taking place but it does
mean that the members budget working
group and and officers will be getting
together earlier ra earlier rather than
later to have a good look at possible
savings
options so the last slide chair just
brings together the recommendations to
council and this is for the increase to
council tax up to the maximum level
we're allowed to set without a
referendum of
2.99% to restate the net revenue budget
at 12.94
million and to outline the contribution
to reserves as shown in section
11 and and key of course in maintaining
Financial Health is um is to work again
with the members budget working group
from the summer to to to bring the
revenue budgets back into balance thank
you
well not financial
genius at all but thank you Gordon for
that I thought it was a very good report
that um easily explained for somebody
like me to understand thanks for that I
do like some of the graphics in here the
very
descriptive uh the ones that
show the council tax increases from 1617
to 2425
proposed um and torage have' got what
less than 28% less than 27 and a half%
over that period when the county have
gone up by 42% over police over 58
nearly
59% fire bit less than those at 24.6 but
Parish Council have gone up a lot but
then again Parish councils have had to
take on a lot of expenses that they
didn't have in the past from the
district some from the district but a
lot from the county but um I'm happy to
move this report chair I think we we
could put some of this information in
our council tax bills when they go out
some some of those SC uh graphs are well
worth sticking a couple of them in there
because they're very descriptive on
their own and people would understand
more then when you mentioned at the
start about our how housing of homeless
people what percentage do we get back we
don't pay all of it I mean we paid over
a million pounds in the last year out
housing people in hotels Etc but we get
a percentage back but not all of it do
we from central government it's
different depending on the housing
placement as I understand it and for our
hostiles we get a a a a a good
proportion of of the contribution back
but for the B&B type accommodation it's
much much lower it's a it's a fixed sum
isn't it yeah and it never matches Hotel
accommodation does it so that's where
the real cost comes into torage isn't it
so you know if we show 1.1 1.2 million
spent on the
homeless it's not necessarily all that
that is torage money though a proportion
of it is torage money that is torage
money that's Tor M but the gross cost so
what we what we've reclaimed has already
been discounted
then yes that that's the net so that is
a cost to T rate pays yes thanks good
thank you chair um yeah thank you very
much for excellent report um I think
I've got my head around most of it but
um on the climate front and um John
winers explained to me several times
that we're waiting for a property
assessment before we can go ahead with
uh energy efficient measures which of
course will reduce cost of this Council
um can you just tell me what within this
budget what particular line or of the
budget will be
used um to fund energy reduction
measures would it come under the
property maintenance budget
or with there's budget within this for
repairs and maintenance maintenance ad
hoc um repairs fixing of things painting
things that kind of things related to
our existing buildings if there was a
particular oneoff phase of improvements
or energy impres then we'd seek a
capital bid for
it thank you that would be next next
year the following Financial year
presumably not this financial year or
would it
be well the the property manager will
come to us when the condition
maintenance surveys and things have been
completed with um with a schedule of
Works sorry the other thing is just that
the property budget 75,000 is it going
on to 20 20 whatever 28 I mean seems
quite a low budget really I'm not just
thinking of the uh Energy Efficiency
measures I'm just thinking of the state
of torage properties really which a lot
of them are deteriorating really badly
it seems quite a low figure to me I mean
bearing in mind obviously the financial
constraints of this
Council that that that figure is just
the revenue contribution to reserves
there' also be a revenue budget for ad
hoc repairs and
maintenance what will be that budget
then sorry I'm get very confused here
I'm sorry I don't know if that off top
of my head right thank
you yeah just a point couple of other
points I guess we we did talk last week
about Energy Efficiency of the the
council's uh swimming pools when we
indicated bid to the decarbonization
fund um if that's for example if that
gets approved and we get the funding
then there may be a requirement to come
back to the committee and ask for for
match funding likewise many of our large
capital projects like our appledor
project for example have them built into
them that they will be energy efficient
efficiency measures within them and
that's the way that those kind of things
are fed into the the budget line and as
Gordon highight giv our property team
have a range of budgets for managing
General day-to-day repairs and things so
it's not just that that single loan but
gord's already and explained that
doesn't seem to be either the budget is
not big enough or the maintenance isn't
been done
because the state of suon our properties
is I there was a recent report from the
national was IT Auditor or something
saying what it was force economy not to
spend on property to maintain
it we're
sort harboring problems for ourselves in
the future so just a general comment
that our properties are deteriorating it
seems to
me thank you chair i' I'd just like to
Second the recommendations and just a
little bit of an explanation as you know
I have the pleasure of chairing the
budget working group and we did save 7
800,000 on the previous uh budget
however the margins will get Tighter and
Tighter we we will have have problems
saving um the money we probably do need
to save um I think just on the hosing
thing because I just explain that the
ones that are hosed in hotels and some
of the properties fall under the lha
which is the local hosing allowance
which is not moved for five or six years
and there is a campaign nationally for
it to be lifted but any money that comes
in at whatever level it's paid for over
taxes and that comes from us so we're
pushing quite hard to get the LFA moved
upwards and it's a very funny way it's
done it's like exitor is different to
North Dev and stuff like that and it
tends to work against us at torage so
the more we can do ourselves in hosing
um the need um the better off we are
because we recover the full rents rather
than the LFA and there it's about a four
time four times multiple on that side of
things so so there was money to be saved
there but we are subject to government
policy as well so we will be the budget
goop will be reconvening and looking at
it and I only hope when we come forward
with recommendations unlike last CNR is
that people take account of the fact
that is really hard goinging and at the
end of the day we have to B balance the
budget and I have said to when David was
doing it I don't really want to see our
reserves completely used up
because once you do that you've use your
reserves up so we we need to look at
what we can do to improve or save to
keep our budget
balanced thank you
chair
yes absolutely
um well well at the moment we've got um
base rates are at
5.25% and we can get returns in the
market of around 5.6 5.7 something like
that and the Assumption for next year is
that we get
4% that that that assumes we get quite a
lot yes so that assumes we get 4% on an
average balance of of of 20 million so
but that again that's another volatile
area as well and we could find a lot of
money being um being applied in other
directions earlier than that as well of
course so our cash balances could be
much
lower well will we budget based on what
we think we will get but there's more of
an upside than a downside I would say in
that
case
to of that and I've also put questions
to interno which I also find very
disappointed by their answer as well I
have to say well all I can say at this
stage Council penitent is I'll look into
that and come back to you I know it's
been discussed but I haven't got any
answers for you at this moment but I
will look at
it
um it's a good report thank you Gordon
um but what I'm taking away from this is
that even if we go with recommendations
to increase council tax and um even if
we have a favorable um interest rate for
the hold of next year um we ultimately
will still be looking at our fees and
charges after we vocate this uh which we
inevitably will and we will still be
raising everything for our Council
taxpayers who are getting less and less
and less for their money and I've been
to five Parish Council meetings in the
past week or week and a half um where by
there have been presentations from Devon
County Council or councilors and they
have no holes Bard sat there and said
that the majority of money that needs
spending on our roads is going to be
channeled into the areas with the most
residents which effectively means that
our area is not getting
anything so we vote for this our
residents still get less and after we
voted for this and it's gone through
they then get the increase in fees and
charges
inevitably
again it's just one hit after another
and what really concerns me is we have a
full Council to discuss Devolution
coming our way which is going to Devon
County Council and tbay where does that
leave
us do do we act seriously are we going
to get any money spent here are our
residents actually getting anything for
their council tax because I don't think
they
are do get
education the
roads I felt it was disgraceful that
they are using the hs2 money to improve
the roads in Devon they've been given a
lot of money
and the only piece that's coming to
Torrid out of 30 OD pieces was Winkle
airr uh it does make me wonder what the
rest of the county councilors in Tor are
doing soci Serv yes that is hammering it
I do accept
that but there we are we're here to
discuss another matter today which is
our
budget can Jes you wish to speak well I
just take councilor dart's point you
know the allocation of funding from the
county but it rather avoids The Wider
issue of huge reductions in money and
public services from the
government and uh you know if we're
going to increase our charges here we're
providing services for the community and
seems to be national government is just
reducing everything so you need the
wider
context
the complaints about um hard up you know
and no money and it's hitting everyone
if you actually look family receipts
have gone up exactly the same
level so we keep talking about the hard
up but everything's going up and incomes
councelor James you wish to speak yeah
thank you chair I've lost some of my
track now but um we we've recently I've
I've took part and I know our chief exec
and it's no detriment to him we the dcn
of which we're a part of which is the
district council Network um a quite a
big group not all the districts but
quite a big group of us and I've worked
with in room at North Devon we did Lobby
hard for an increase in our rural
settlement and they have come up with a
small amount and our deficit would be
worse if that hadn't come up so that was
announced on Friday I think last Friday
Thursday Friday so collectively as
districts we are fighting for it in
terms of the
Devolution I did in a meeting last week
make it quite clear I was concerned when
it come to consultation and listening
were we actually listening to the people
because as a district as you say it's
going to be Devon and tbay but as a
district we Supply most of the services
that affect people apart from the roads
and as councelor Piper would have
discovered and I've discovered I was
quite hard getting here this morning
because all of a sudden they seem to be
wanting to spend the money now so I
don't know whether there's a March
deadline on it but after five or six
years of lobbying if you went to visit
me you would have needed a tractor to
drive down the main little bit of road
where you come off a Cornwall Highway
through a Devon and then onto a Cornwall
Highway and we have finally got that
piece of road done this took at least
six years so they are doing bits but I I
think the thing about the uh council tax
is if we don't put it up to that figure
the council will assume that we don't
need it uh the government will assume we
don't need it and so they will probably
take that off the money they give us so
we have two steps backwards so um it's a
difficult time but we're not giving up
on it we are really fighting everything
we can to try and help but as I say any
tax comes out of our pocket don't matter
who gives it to us who spends it it
comes out of our
pocket
thank you chair um good morning
counselors and everyone um so I'm just
going to do a quick uh presentation on
the capital program and the update going
forwards for
2425 um next slide please Kirsty thanks
so Capital program covers the next five
years um it consists of approved
projects by for Council and it's funded
by a mixture of reserves uh
contributions from revenue capital rece
seats and
grants the brought forward capital
program that was um approved by for
Council in February
23 had a value of 26.8 million with
funding of
29.1 uh leaving a surplus of just over
two
million next slide please thank you
K so we have a couple of new projects we
have one new PID um which is the one
which uh John the it manager has always
already discussed about the new wise
boxes
um yeah so there's one new PID which is
the um which was already discussed by
John which is the new wise boxes for the
desktop strategy then we also have
Community Land trusts now this is a
revolving Loan Fund now there's a bit of
history on this one which is back in
2019 um 600,000 of borrowing was
authorized by Full Count
to fund Community Land Trust revolving
Loan Fund um so the the details in the
report but the key points really are all
loans would be approved by CNR um loans
are from between 75 to
150,000 and they're secured with a legal
charge against the land or the property
interest would be charged at a
comparable uh rate that's the pwb rate
which is the Public Works loan board
which is the rate that torage can borrow
borrow at and it's intended for
shortterm Lending um five years or less
to sort of get these projects um
completed
really so with those two updates and
there was also some movement on the
capital program during the year there
were 20.7 million of new capital
projects added during
2324 that's primarily uh down to the
appor clean Mar Maritime Innovation
Center uh the details in one of the
appendixes in the report when all that's
added up that shows our Capital program
has grown uh tremendously over the year
um to just over 47 million with 50
million of uh expected and forecasted
funding this gives rise to A3 million
pound Surplus on the capital program now
the bottom bit of this slide um sort of
brings in the vehicle program to add a
bit of context because that3 million
pound of funding um is a little bit due
to the program being over five years so
what that is is the vehicle program um
we're looking longterm to fund our Fleet
over the next couple of uh major
Replacements all the way out to
3233 now with the capital program we're
just looking at five years so what that
means is at the end of the five years
the vehicle program we've saved up 2
million um to buy some more vehicles in
a few years time so really that3 million
pound Surplus is only really a million
pound Surplus on the general program I
hope that makes
sense next slide please
thanks so this leaves us where we are
currently with the capital program and
that's to say we've got the million
pound Surplus but there are some
pressures that the capital program is
under I've listed a few of the pressures
there we've got um got Leisure centers
where had estimates in the past of 60
ground a year 60,000 a year of capital
maintenance costs we've got the
transition to Net Zero and various costs
associated um got any new projects in
the next five years none of those have
been forecasted in at the present we've
also got the linear defense um Works
which we're working with the environment
agency towards uh future inflation on
current projects and uh the aquador
clean Maritime invent Innovation Center
which also has some pressure on the
funding
envelope um on top of that there are
there is obviously some um more positive
news which is uh torage was identified
one of 20 councils to form a partnership
with the leveling uh well a leveling up
partnership with the government and of
those 20 councils there's 400 million of
funding um majority of that or so
whatever tor's share of that becomes so
we expected it to be larg largely
Capital um
though funding will likely be signed off
on a project by project basis um and
there will be quite a short time scale
is what we're expecting at the
moment so that that sort of sums up my
um sums up the presentation and really
it's just a recommendation for members
to recommend full Council um that it's
updated to include the incline PCS and
the Community Land Trust revolving Loan
Fund thank
you
do we get an enabling officer with the
fund because we don't have one
still not with that F that's capital
funding so you can't use Capital money
for Revenue funding uh but we're very
close to going out
to yeah thank you chair um this just a
Community Land Trust um just noting that
no take up has occurred since
2019 I just wonder given our huge
financial constraints whether that's a a
good um subject for our spending really
whether it should be the spending should
be I mean that's an allocated figure
which you can't do anything else with
presumably so would be better spent on a
on an alternative housing
issue well I mean I I'm not totally
aware of how this works but it's that's
just my immediate
well the the idea was that um that it's
funded from borrowing so we would borrow
the 600,000 to loan out and obviously
charge an interest equivalent to the
cost that would cost the council so
there wouldn't be much cost so there
wouldn't really be any cost to the
council other than officers time um but
obviously it would help um the provision
of affordable housing so we haven't
allocated anything towards it it's just
purely borrowing yes
yeah
yeah on page 57 there's a whole list of
items and one of them says um Victoria
Park um pars and services is that
affected At All by what's going on in
Victoria Park at the moment or is that a
separate issue that's a separate Pro
program so what does that cover then 110
pars and
services
um I'm not sure the detail myself
yeah
so will not that be revised then that
some when all the works are done at
Victor
part
not
not disabled
access
color coded then sh this this table at
the end Capital
program is that a is that a color coding
that well what do the what do the colors
mean again
I can't see any key here I think it was
just to break it out into the different
sort of categories of the of the of the
projects just to ask about the de
provision does that apply to the de
top on page same page 57 page
million CH that's that's the budget
that's been pre previously allocated by
the council for the operational Services
Depo or however you want to
it
not thank you um with reference to
CT
discussion with other districts to
consider how important are to actually
drive forward now I
believe that there is the opportunity
for us to
utilize
stimulate
details but I'm aware
and I would not to
600,000
while is
OPP Horizon
[Music]
maroun James is
involved interest here so it is rather
difficult for to
share issues that you may
toed
interest
I as
AA
esps of
oural and
Rel
yeah just on that point about Community
Land Trust um it's probably not a
decision now that we can make all but at
for Council couple of months ago did we
not agree that letters will be sent out
to Parish Council was asking for local
land owners to put forward their ideas
to put into these Community Land drafts
I'm not aware that such letters have
been sent out to Paris
Council CH yes we are ready ready to
send the the Letters Out um what we want
to indicate on the letters is a forum
for those parish and town councils to
come back to and we were planning to use
the a Advisory Group meetings for that
but one of the chairs is away on
holidays uh so we haven't uh do back
this week and then we'll set a date then
those letters will go out so they are
imminent any else wish to
speak
page